simpsons check family guy you're next
last week's flu scare got me thinking
i don't know anything about my genetic
makeup or what other illnesses i might
be susceptible to you know what's funny
about this there's actually a genetic
test for dogs i actually did it for bear
and roxy turns out they
are what we thought they were they were
who we thought they were so it made me
want to do a 23andme genetic test
i think the one i did was called embark
i'm predisposed to like caffeine
so true that's such a problem with these
genetic tests oh my god like so many of
them will give you information that is
genetically accurate to some degree
and then they tell you something that
you cannot practically act on at all you
know uh we have a higher likelihood that
you may uh
live five years less than a normal
person would
okay what do i do with that what uses it
to know that you or potentially have a
higher risk for alzheimer's disease it's
just like flexing
the genetic people are like ugh
don't have the alzheimer's gene that's
good see i knew it and it says i don't
have the alzheimer's gene so that's good
how would you like to be a male nurse do
i get to wear those green pajama clothes
all day
yes aka scrubs they're not although they
are kind of comfy like pajamas today i
need you to observe surgery
my sister can attach ventricles better
than you why are they attaching
ventricles of the heart i'm so confused
with surgery he was looking at i could
have sworn the abdomen was open in that
seat
there are operating theaters where you
can watch operations be performed it's
great for residents fellows
even other doctors that are trying to
learn i don't think they let family
members do that i have seen it on grey's
anatomy but i've never seen it in real
life
it goes to show that looks like a weird
ecg
pattern oh flatline
you know what we do chest compressions
chest compressions chest compressions
code
come on you got to live damn it i need
you okay those are
not those are not good chest
compressions remember
okay so acls uh advanced cardiac life
support would not tell you to punch a
chicken in the face
just want to put that out for the record
what are you doing peter i'm making my
own red bull lois can't stop me from
experiencing the manic highs and lows my
body demands
kerosene why is he putting kerosene in
it red bull has a lot of stuff in it
like 80 milligrams of caffeine
chlorine if you want a caffeine boost
like just have a cup of coffee it's
it's more natural there's actually
polyphenols in there because it's
plant-based
coffee beans are just better for your
health at least our research shows that
that drink will kill you
ryan whatever kills me makes me stronger
i think i think he messed that one up
see brian i feel great
peter peter you alive poison hotline
stat
by the way did you know that there's a
nationwide poison hotline all the toxic
chemicals your husband
ingested from his homemade energy drink
have caused total kidney failure
total kidney failure requires dialysis
and quickly where you essentially take
the blood outside the body clean it
and process it the way the kidneys do
and put it back into the body we'll put
him on a kidney transplant list but that
could take months
until a donor is found he's gonna have
to undergo dialysis treatments three
times a week
dialysis is there any other way
what about me what's the difference
between a dog kidney and a human kidney
i have
no idea like i assume it's similar but i
feel like dog kidneys might not last
as long i don't know bear i would never
harvest your organs i
will not ever harvest your kidneys they
are yours
and even if we are a match i will make
sure you get to keep them why are you so
messy
chances are peter never would have
survived the surgery i mean i mean
dog kidneys i'm not even sure dogs have
kidneys
what the dogs have kidneys yes yeah this
this is the guy
this is what i felt like maybe you put
on a few pounds sweetie lois i weigh the
same 293 pounds today that i weighed in
grade school
perhaps it's this lump on the side of
your neck sir oh my god
peter how long have you had that thing i
i don't know
we got to go see dr hartman right away
quick differential diagnosis
cushing's syndrome lipoma soft tissue
mask
like a sarcoma could it be a lymphoma
and he has a swollen lymph node there i
guess that's possible as well
no you're stupid oh hello griffins what
can i help you with today that should be
a warning sign if you walk into a
doctor's office and they're just yelling
at a patient
you're stupid dr hartman peter has a
huge lump growing on his neck
mrs griffin that's called a head i've
been fooled by that one before but when
you take a look at it i think it might
be a tumor
okay let's have a look it appears you
have a subcutaneous vestigial twin
growing on your neck
is he saying that it's a teratoma with
just by touching it i mean that's
very impressive that he was able to
diagnose it so much so
that it is not real a teratoma is
basically a type of tumor that has
all sorts of different stem cells in it
where they start growing different cell
lines like
hair teeth muscle you cut it open and
there's just like almost a twin in there
like it's crazy like you could have
human remains almost now hold still i'm
just going to give you a little topical
anaesthetic and we'll have a closer look
what ow that would not you would you'd
need
injection anesthetic a little lidocaine
hi everybody
he did a skin flap though that's
impressive get up we're late
oh he does not look good he looks like
he has anemia
potentially some dehydration there oh my
god jaundice like there's a little
yellowing of the eyes how did this
happen
it's from smoking oh not that bad peter
you can't live like this
i'm taking you to dr hartman oh i hate
the doctor
are you sure there are cheez-its in
there
jesus it's like a vet visit i'm not
gonna lie i have some patients that come
in and i'm like oh like once last time
you were to a doctor they're like
you know like three four years uh mostly
because i hate going to see the doctor i
hate doctors
and i'm like
hey mr griffin i'm gonna need to ask you
a few questions
do you think i can jump and touch that
pipe up there i don't know why i always
used to do that as a kid street signs
crosswalk signs scaffoldings was always
can you touch that you think you can
touch that five bucks if i could touch
that dr hartman we're here for you to
help peter quit smoking mrs griffin i
can't do that
it's an addiction oh you gotta do
something well we absolutely can do
something about that not only do we have
behavioral treatment options for it but
we have pharmaceutical options for it
including nicotine patches
oral medications all of them are not
right for everybody and you have to do
an individual discussion with your
doctor to figure out what's right for
you and the first step of quitting
is contemplating quitting i guess even
before that is understanding why
quitting is important
but dr hartman why did he lose
consciousness well keeping in mind the
recent behavioral changes you've
described i did a cat scan
on a dog oh that's actually pretty funny
a cat's kid on a dog god we're such
nerds however i'm sorry to inform you
that brian
has a brain tumor oh no so doc
um how much jamba juice do i have to
drink to cure this
um i i've also heard that like crystals
exist
he's been reading a little bit too much
of goop.com do you think the brain tumor
might explain why brian's been acting so
odd lately
hmm well i haven't heard of brains being
linked to behavior but i suppose
anything is possible well it says here
brian's tumor is for
office use only ah benign it says benign
tumors can either be described as benign
or malignant malignant meaning that
they're problematic they can spread
they can actually cause you to die
benign tumors usually
the only way they cause a problem is if
they can turn malignant or
if they become big enough in size where
they exhibit mass effect putting
pressure on other structures
causing them to malfunction is my father
gonna be okay
it's that house md he's in a coma mrs
griffin oh they got gregory house for
this
wow dr house if you're gonna save this
patient you'll need this
get this thing out i'm eyesight
wait is that not even him is that
someone doing his voice really well
wait a second how are you gonna play by
the rules if you don't have the rule oh
yeah my methods are a little unorthodox
mr griffin
i think i can help oh what are you doing
my job
sometimes people fake being in a coma
this man's not unless of course the
first punch knocked him off
he literally is the type of doctor
that's like all right i think it could
be this
let's poison the patient and see if they
recover and i'm like that's
not really how you practice medicine sir
i think you should know these growths on
your forearms
they're giant tumors i just realized
popeye was not a healthy character
why are the forearms huge and the biceps
tiny and then second of all what's with
the pipe is he
always smoking because that's not
healthy no matter how much spinach you
eat and the speech thing and what you're
doing with your eye
uh you had a stroke about seven years
ago
that would make sense because if you
aren't able to open your eye maybe uh
[Music]
bell's pulse god lost my mind maybe he
has bell's palsy that you've managed to
be walking around all this time is
nothing short of a miracle
i'd say about two months i'd say he
should stop smoking uh he should go to
the gym and meet with the physical
therapist and figure out why he's
lifting solely with his forearms
and not his upper body you should get a
vasectomy first of all i don't know what
that is and second of all no freaking
way
peter it's the male equivalent of a
woman getting her tubes tied except it's
actually a lot quicker and safer
let these guys explain
[Music]
it is and some people say it's
reversible but that's not really a good
way to think about it while it can be
reversed in some cases you should think
of it as a permanent change
excuse me you still should be wearing a
condom because of
sti protections
why do they say goodbye to manhood like
it prevents unwanted pregnancies what
does manhood have to do with it
all the incredible information you need
to know about underwear right here
i said underwear yeah my underwear your
underwear we're talking about it
click here and as always stay happy